Luke Vargas joins me today from
Singapore he's the chief foreign
correspondent for talk media news he
also hosts the weekly foreign policy
radio show and podcast wake with luke
vargas he was he's not just vacationing
in singapore he actually has been there
for the trump kim jong hoon summit and
let's sort of start with the basics Luke
I mean talk about the setting talk about
the structure of the meetings what can
we glean sort of not so much from the
actual paper that was signed but from
body language and kind of like the
flavor of what's been going on there
well I've been here for a while and I'm
gonna be here longer than apparently I
need to be there was some talk among the
white house planners that everything was
ready for this to possibly go into a
second day and as we'll talk about later
the fact that the deal met that rapport
was strong the deal making was occurring
right even after the unike was signed
I'm not quite sure and I wish I could
have asked President Trump or someone
else why did it get this someone could
cut off where it got cut off but that's
a matter for another day this is the
perfect place in my view for a
high-stakes international summit
Singapore maybe like a country like Oman
which also plays one of these unique
sort of regional power brokering roles
has figured out most of its domestic
issues and kind of like a really good
friend and a stable relationship is just
there to help you out you know and and
they're eager to pick up the tab and and
you know handle the security for foreign
dignitaries and I have to say the this
is the safest city in the world
according to a number of different
studies and I think in many ways that
was palpable just going to all these
conference events I mean there was
security and a big military presence but
I've had you know encountered more more
militaristic security approach to events
in New York City and I think a lot of
that has to do with the fact that
Singapore is so safe there's not a lot
of other through the factors that could
really mess this whole sum it up the
summit itself not that interesting in
many ways if it was not the in my view
the pomp and circumstance even at the
DMZ meeting between North Korea and
South Korea and April where you had all
these military honor guards and music
and and all these photo ops there are
some of that yesterday but not quite as
much it's
started with a 40-minute meeting face to
face some people were as freaking out
about this historians and journalists
because there was no one else in the
room other than the heads of state and
their translators I sort of saw this is
a good thing and these are two leaders
that do need to get to know each other
and and if the goal here is to avert you
know a nuclear war then even spending 40
minutes talking about cars or New York
City nightlife is better than you know
not having a chance just to look into
your adversaries eyes so that's how it
begins then relatively boilerplate two
and a half three hours of bilateral
meetings and culminating in this signed
agreement we'll get to that one second
and body language I think in many ways
Kim Jong Un's body language was the one
to watch I think we know how President
Trump comports himself I thought Kim in
many ways was mirroring Trump at points
he's a man who's shorter and that's
always been a concern to his aides who
have wanted to make sure get overpowered
when standing next to Trump I thought
Kim did a great job sort of matching his
posture and gait if you look at these
photos of the two men walking down these
colonnades at the hotel they are almost
walking in precisely unison with each
other I think that's Kim
mirroring Trump not the other way around
and yet I also thought Kim in many ways
is cognizant that you know for his
propaganda film makers he wants to give
them two types of summits right he wants
to give them enough material that looks
like he's affable a genial man who's
willing to play nice with an adversary
but also subtle physical gestures
putting his hand on Trump's back as he
they walk out of a room that if any
point where the relationship goes south
again he can say look you know I I you
know was walking this guy around and
leading him everywhere and so I thought
he was certainly very conscious of the
way he was appearing on cameras yeah and
maybe some elements have shared bonding
over food I mean neither of them is
particularly trim and and that that may
have been something that that led to the
furthering of the possibility of
international peace negotiations but
let's get to the actual joint statement
that was put out right which my analysis
not to redo it all for you now but my
analysis was not unlike that that of
some others I thought that what most of
what was in the agreement the joint
statement was relatively unremarkable
mirroring commitments that have been
both vague and unenforceable from North
in the past and I'm curious how was the
content of that statement communicated
to you guys to press that were there
terribly we were all stuck on in buses
about 200 or so journalists dividin it's
not just you know people like me or even
sort of younger journalists it was
network news anchors and Hannity was on
another bus I saw Hertz from Fox News
you know slumped against a doe and a hot
bus waiting in traffic all of us were
stuck in the middle of Singapore traffic
trying to get to the press conference
several hours later and everyone's
huddled around cellphones trying to
listen to the signing statements and
then trying to figure out what had been
signed I mean the White House is
spinning this already everyone's talking
about a historic deal yet nobody knows
what has actually been signed and the
White House doesn't send anything
officially until three hours later which
is an hour into Trump's hour and five
minute press conference and so if I
understand correctly Trump's doing the
press conference he's already well into
the press conference bragging about what
was achieved but that's the content of
the statement that they signed had not
yet been communicated to the press
that's correct I mean they're Bloomberg
I believe was the photography pool for
the signing statement and they had a
telephoto lens of course and zoomed in
and one of their reporters they probably
kept it in-house for a minute and try to
analyze it but then they sort of started
circulating snippets of it but I guess
it's always possible that something else
was signed or the formal agreement was
different than what was brought to the
table so we didn't really report on and
fully but yeah in the press conference
you can hear Trump sort of saying
everyone's seen this and the reporters
including myself started shouting back
no we haven't and a finally he gets the
message and sort of says hey guys send
it to them but they still don't do it
for you know 25 minutes or something
it's back to the content of the document
it's really four paragraphs at the end
of the day the joke is that these things
called joint communique zuv which this
was a sort was a communique to
communicate that it really didn't have
much meat on it the four key elements
two of them I think we can just toss out
right away they're very vague pledges to
build a peace regime on the Korean
Peninsula to revitalize the relationship
and there's nothing wrong with even
saying you're going to revitalize the
relationship but one would have expected
something more a date for exchanging
ambassador
maybe a pledge to create a special
interest section or interest section in
Pyongyang and maybe one in DC but again
that's very vague there is a nuclear
line which says that essentially there's
no new language here that they're going
to stick up for the pamela zhang
declaration which is from April that's
the document that was signed at the end
of the DMZ summit and that document also
if you go into that it's a little bit
longer than this but it also just talks
about phased disarmament and doesn't
have the new specifics and that was
purposeful that document was crafted
because there was an expectation that
when Trump and Kim met there'd be more
robust nuclear language that would
supersede it and of course that hasn't
happened and now the pennmen jean
declaration looks beefier than this
and the final point which having just
read the Korean Central News Agency
North Korean propaganda story about
appears like it was a spontaneous ask
from Trump which was relating to the
POVs getting back the remains of people
you know Americans who died or were
captured in North Korea in the 1950s
during the Korean War and whose remains
are still there and seemingly on the
spot according to the Koreans that you
know Kim just acceded to this demand and
that was the fourth of the four
paragraphs but imagine this document
which already looks weak lacking that
paragraph one that Trump was talking up
repeatedly during the press conference
there isn't a lot of meat on the bone so
let's talk about the press conference
you were in the third row during the
press conference and there were a number
of sort of unusual elements during this
press conference once was that there was
this video that we would have assumed
was North Korean propaganda it was
actually produced by the White House and
we were talking about that on the
program today also there were references
sort of offhandedly to additional
provisions that Trump and Kim jong-un
sort of discussed verbally after the
joint statement was signed which of
course exists nowhere on paper and make
this entire thing even more bizarre in
my mind which is that it seems as though
the differences between this negotiation
and prior negotiations exist only
verbally and took place after the
signing of the document that was
published
yeah well that notion of a tossin is a
real-estate term I mean you do these
once you sign something on paper then
the landlord is throw
in all sorts of concessions and the the
new you know tenant is excited oh the
landlord's listening to my demands but
conveniently they're all you know verbal
agreements and you can never point to a
lease and say hey you know we we you
said you were gonna dismantle that
nuclear site like you know install the
new washing machine so yeah I mean
there's a huge gulf between the deal
that's on paper and the deal president
Trump seems he you know think about in
his head let's talk first about the
video which startled all the reporters
there was no introduction to this and it
was a Korean first they played it in
Korean and then looped it all back again
so it's like a five minute video played
twice for us and we did actually think
it was in North Korean you know
multimedia material that was brought and
it had all all parts and if you've seen
at risk of identify denting the Donald
Trump offspring is either Eric or Donald
Trump jr. who had a promotional video
for a new like a shared workspace living
community in Dumbo and Brooklyn and it
looked a lot I mean you know I would be
not surprised if it was the same sort of
marketing team that did both of these
videos it has all this you know it's the
hallmark you know stock footage of a
basketball player with no uniform
dunking on a court on a parquet with no
logos on it either it's like and then
shots of the condos in South Beach this
was apparently a video Donald Trump
played to Kim and I was thinking like if
you're a US ally let's add Botswana
who's like doing most things right and
but they could be better the economy is
ok but why not have a much more
prosperous economy are you gonna get any
sort of presentation from Trump like
become our friend and like we'll make
make you the country of your dreams no
he's giving this pitch to a guy who's
you know a murderous dictator that also
seemed odd and then we'll talk about the
tossings I mean so the biggest one of
course is a concession from the US which
isn't anywhere on paper and it's
possible like other things
Trump has demanded of the military that
they are going to wait for some more
formal order to in this case stop the
joint military exercises with South
Korea and maybe they'll never actually
get it certainly Trump's decision to
call these war games
to say they aren't necessary for
American and Korean security that
they're too expensive that Korea isn't
footing enough of the bill the Pentagon
doesn't share those beliefs and is
operating on the assumption that they
work the military exercises are going to
continue the other tossin czar
concessions coming from North Korea
saying they're going to destroy a
missile facility of saying that they're
going to stop nuclear and ballistic
missile tests again that would be a
really nice thing to have in writing
because they have never agreed to that
formally before but Trump seems to thank
this again most important nuclear
related matters of this whole summit are
it's fine to just leave those as in sort
of informal handshake agreements and of
course there's an innocent explanation
here and a cynical one the innocent one
being look this is their very sensitive
issues they don't want to mess them up
they don't want to be premature and
putting language out there that both
sides might not agree to and there is
agreement on all sorts of fronts they're
just going to wait a few weeks to put it
on paper the much more cynical
explanation which I'm somewhat more
inclined to believe is that you know
take take out the pow2 man that Trump
apparently had the last minute which did
gets you know moved into the agreement
and there actually isn't anything these
guys are not the positions are not
converging despite all the recent
meetings and Trump goes up to the podium
saying shoot I didn't agree to anything
let me just sort of start talking about
some unicorn deal that doesn't exist
will it into existence and that's that
would be concerning of course Luke in
the limited time we have left
lack of nuclear knowledge seemed to be a
theme of the press conference that that
happened there in other words Trump
talked a lot hyperbolically
about successes but it didn't really
seem as though he knew much about sort
of how so-called nuclear works how
disarmament would work or really any of
the logistics he didn't and he also keep
one of the details that would be really
nice to have is what is this ballistic
site related to the engine program of
the ballistic missile program in North
Korea that they're going to destroy
because there's already one called a
hari it's the driver and engine facility
I think and and that's already slated
for destruction so if that's what it is
then this is a really a nothing burger
negotiation point he agreed to destroy
something that's slated for destruction
right the other bits are this tweet sent
from Air Force one where Trump says now
the nuclear issue is off the table of
course that impossible unless the
nuclear threat is removed or destroyed
which it hasn't been and this also
notion from Trump that you know and I
think he said this in the press
conference that you know once you start
to even partially take apart the nuclear
program the threat but the rest sort of
just figure it solves itself which is
the opposite of what experts say which
is that even if you get rid of all the
material and all the launch sites you
still have in North Korea at least a
whole you know sort of rank and file of
thousands of nuclear scientists who
possess intimate knowledge of how to get
back to that nuclear threshold again and
unless you retrain them or give them
something else to do they're a very
potent political force in North Korea
and they also hold the keys to
restarting that program so what he talks
about nuclear weapons just signals he
doesn't really know what he's talking
about Luke we're gonna keep following it
question what has been the most
interesting or unique a food item you've
had while in Singapore gosh I haven't
been terribly adventurous I'm trying to
think there the Marriott hotel which
sponsored the journalists had buffets
every night and there were some odd sea
creature salads with without much
garnish that I largely stayed away from
them but other than that it was sort of
american-style dining for the last few
days so now that I'm caught up on sleep
and all the diplomats of left town I am
gonna branch out and see the rest of the
city all right Luke Vargas chief foreign
correspondent for talk media news
unseasoned sea creature salads you heard
it here first that was one of the big
revelations from the summit in Singapore
Luke pleasure as always to be talking to
you thanks David talk to you soon